for the next
45 minutes i would like to share some of
my work with you
that
i brand as extended reality for
everybody and it is when i started here
at the university of michigan i
was working with a lot of
students interested and familiar with
user experience interaction design and
as i developed my my own research
interests more in augmented reality in
virtual reality
um i noticed it's actually really
difficult to create these experiences
unless you have a training in for
example computer science
and so
part of my mission here at the
university has been to allow
and enable
various designers
that includes
user experience interaction designers to
prototype and work with these
technologies and
now when you are in this area you forget
how hard a tool like unity is and so if
some of you are more advanced in the
audience so
i hope you can still empathize with the
fact that
it is not easy
to create these experiences so a lot of
the talk will be
sharing some of the techniques i have
developed in the past
working with designers non-technical so
not necessarily programmers and then the
second portion of the talk i want to
focus more on a new audience that i'm
engaging which is instructors so people
who teach
any kind of topic
and want to use arvr so i also want to
enable them to make use of ar and vr in
their teaching
so i'll um
i'll show you a video
of
what i do in some of my courses so in an
online series of courses that i've
created
which i call the xr mooc specialization
one of the things i try to do in my
courses is actually use
not so much now overzoom but actually
use ar vr in these courses so you'll see
an example of me
being in vr
but you get a mixed reality perspective
on me so i will get some of these terms
out of the way very soon
and you can see how i explain the
different concepts i mean the the actual
sketch of what i produce is relatively
simple i could have used it 2d sketch
but the interesting part is the
instructor in this case is directly in
the environment you can also see if you
wonder how we did this
you can also see that we shot it in
front of a green screen and that's
actually not even technically necessary
anymore and
and so part of my mission is to enable
other people not just michael
uh to do this kind of stuff uh
for design and for teaching
and um
i want to
give you
the way so the way i've structured this
talk
and it may not have been the smartest
thing i have done but i wanted to give
you an overview of the work that i have
done rather than present
some of the recent papers that i'm
excited about in this overview you will
see a little bit of my mission and some
of the flavors and the research themes
that i've been following
so i've listed them on the slide and
i've been very intrigued by the fact how
uh most people
confuse concepts like virtual and
augmented reality even and then adding a
new term like mixed reality uh to what
kinds of misconceptions that that
led so i've been studying this i've been
studying key barriers to entry it's been
very fascinating to me what are the main
challenges for
maybe non-programmers and hobbyists and
domain experts and researchers so i've
been doing some of this more conceptual
work and i share two things here
um
i've been working on most people who
know me think michael is the guy who
builds some arvr tools and gets away
with it publishing them at kai all the
time
and that is true there is actually there
is some truth in it because i do think
building
tools in research
is something that most advisors would
not necessarily recommend it's a lot of
work
um
on the programming on the scoping side
but i wanted to share a few of the
methods and tools i've developed in
research to enable designers
and recently i've looked more into
how do we actually enable people to
collaborate in arvr and there's
interesting work going on at berkeley
and stanford
and you have really cool really cool
professionally trained
computer graphics people so some of the
things i show you here you will probably
find
it's not as technical maybe as
it's actually quite technically behind
the scenes but what i do not present is
like new tracking algorithms or new
sensing techniques that has been or
shape-changing displays you have shown
for that and that has not been so much
the focus of my work i've been really
focused on enabling uh
the design process and adapting it to
arvr and
recently i've looked more into how to do
this inclusively so how do i actually
teach in vr when not every student has
access to a vr headset i mean there's
also us who
who say we design the future
and then there's those of us who
actually live in reality and the fact is
that most students don't have access to
vr headsets so how do we design
for example a vr course in an inclusive
and in a safe way
and i'm also uh putting in some of the
more recent flavors of focus on privacy
and security
so my my trajectory has been
um
making some of these more foundational
contributions on
on on thinking about the challenges and
really driving a lot of the research
within kai some extent
uh the tools which is they're very dear
to me and each of them comes with i
think a cool clever idea and i i
i just wanted to share some of them with
you
and um
and really studying with different
audiences and don't go so much into the
hard like clinical settings or medical
settings but just
shifting from designers and so
non-technical
i mean designers are also technical but
not programmers and now recently working
with instructors really has also shaped
my thinking about how to use these
technologies in teaching
so on the misconceptions side i showed
you a video
where i was in virtual reality and i
said it's a mixed reality view so if you
asked people and we did this in 2019
what is mixed reality and
when you when you talk about these terms
i i've often sensed a lot of uncertainty
about virtual reality and augmented
reality and so in if you took an arvr
course
what your instructor will tell you is
it's clear there is the mergrum reality
virtuality continuum this is the real
world we have an area where we see
increasingly augmented contents of
virtual content overlaid with the real
world
there's something that is a little
harder to grasp but it's the inverse
it's augmented virtuality so you see
mostly virtual content but you
incorporate elements from the physical
world
and then you see the completely virtual
world so
illustrated based on the video that you
saw i said you saw a mixed reality
capture of me so i was technically
michael me was in virtual reality
actually this is the view i had on the
top bottom right here
and obviously it's an occluded headset
so i didn't actually see the environment
around me
i did have a
view on me
that i could use um
to basically sketch against the mirror
and watch a mirror
and then obviously what it actually
looked like in the real world when we
recorded it from the outside it's just
michael in front of a green screen
and this composition in the middle
is really the essence of what mixed
reality does it creates a merged the
composite view of the virtual content
and the real world or the real person in
this case is still mostly the virtual
tilt brush environment behind me
and it can be a very powerful tool
um to exp and you can experience
the person in vr but from a typical
outside camera perspective this
composition can be done in real time we
do not need um
specific post processing even with a
green screen setup it was done in your
time
so when we ask experts i just want to
lay a little bit the foundation here for
the for the lecture
the term mixed reality you get the
different answers not everybody in fact
out of our 10 experts so these are five
from academia and five from industry and
by five experts i mean these are really
senior professors in academia and really
experienced researchers working for some
of the main competent companies in the
field and they couldn't agree on the
terminology what mixed reality actually
is and if we also did a literature
survey tracing back
to milgram's
mixed reality continuum reality
virtually continuing paper but also
more of the industry sources including
microsoft how they hype mixed reality as
a marketing gag
and so the
uh the numbers here don't really matter
but obviously there is relatively little
agreement we in fact found six working
definitions and then uh only a third of
them in line with the reality virtuality
continuum
most people thought mixed reality is
just another term for augmented reality
there are people who think it's the
combination of ai and vr though actually
technically milgram specifically
excludes
if i go back to the original slide then
mixed reality is a spectrum but it
doesn't actually necessarily include
virtual reality and so what i've done in
the past and more recently now is just
use the term extended reality to refer
to everything where x is so x r where x
is the wild card for arvr and mr
and in fact i stay away from using the
term mixed reality because as
demonstrated by the research here
what people understand on this term is
actually very very different
now um so what i advise uh
to students and obviously i'm not
listening to my own advice because
throughout this presentation i will use
the mixed reality term quite a few times
but i use the term mixed reality when
i'm really in between realities or when
i have an interface that
can also be
perceived in augmented and virtual
reality
and there are other notions like
stronger version of ar which is the more
marketing driven
notion and
just it's picked up by a few sources and
also quite a few people
um
so anyway we discussed this in more
detail in our what is mixed reality
paper i think it's an interesting
reading we wrote this paper for anybody
who wants to get started in this space
if somebody is excited at the end of
this talk about arvr
could be a good starting point we also
provide
a better maybe a not a better we provide
a
framework to think through the space and
if you
if you are a trained in interactive
technologies you often
distinguish interactive technologies
based on input and output
that is not necessarily helpful when it
comes to
mixed reality
because if you think if you think of the
six definitions the working definitions
that were used by by our experts in in
in the literature
um distinguishing them
by input and output is actually not
going to be helpful so instead
we describe in more detail in in that
what is mixed early paper a framework
so you would think that along the number
of environments both virtual and
physical that the system wants to
integrate the number of users can have
an impact on whether you would call
something
a certain type of mixed reality
the level of immersion and virtuality
and then finally people distinguish
implicit explicit interaction and with
these
with these components you have a
framework that allows you to analyze
existing experiences and
and for those who care about terminology
it can be very
useful
the other thing i've done is looking at
current practices and challenges and to
be honest uh when i started the research
i was excited about creating a few
different tools and
with with the tools try out what could
be back to better practices and
challenges and in fact the more
foundational research the more
survey-based or interview-based research
on
current practice and challenges i've
actually done a little bit more recently
so this is actually kai
akai 2020 paper on
um
creating augmented and virtuality
application current practices challenges
and opportunities
and this was a project not led by me but
uh
by ash nagas ashtari who is a phd
student with par meet uh chilana
at simon fraser university very exciting
work we interviewed 21
um subjects that would i self-identify
as a range of professional designers
so trained in
in design user experience interaction
design or graphic design domain experts
so these are people excited about aivr
they don't have
fundamental training in design or
computer science
and hobbyists who
who really
just pick up these technologies
as they go they get excited about them
and they don't have like like the domain
experts not necessarily the training
that unity for example assumes and so in
my work i've been studying
with these different kinds of
user groups and
so there is more detail in the paper and
it would be its own presentation
but it is very interesting to think
about where the challenges occur i'm
going to talk to you about the
challenges
and you need to look at the fact how how
rapidly growing the landscape is in
terms of devices and features and
new startups coming out and new startups
dying and google changing its approach
every day and discontinuing this and
that a lot of challenges is that
around designing and prototyping which
is something that i've been focusing on
where a lot of the challenges are
most tools are still difficult to use or
have a very low
ceiling so you can't actually do too
much with them
and so i've been tackling that mostly
and then there's a lot of issues around
how do you actually implement and test
mixed reality experience how do i
determine
whether my new ar experience is actually
good for example for teaching
and whether the user experience is good
so looking at new metrics and so i'll
show you some
i won't go over the details of this
table um
but i wanted to include it what i would
like to focus on is some of the
key barriers to entry that maybe some of
you
if you haven't if you've never if you've
if you've done arb before maybe some of
you have experienced those it's very
very difficult it's very difficult to
know where to start and some people
would just
most instructors just pick unity as the
tool and teach that to their students
that is not my approach and i i think
this the start has to be more
fundamental
with the concepts and really thinking
through the space but if you know how to
use unity it is a good start i'm not
saying it's wrong
it's difficult to make use of online
learning resources is actually
these technologies while
a professor will tell you they have been
around for many years
most people
most practitioners would tell you is
actually they're cutting edge or
bleeding edge technologies and actually
the the
as it is often the case with these new
technologies the online learning
resources are very quickly outdated or
insufficiently documented so it's very
difficult to actually work
if you got your hands on your latest new
quest or whatever and then you try to
work with the pass-through api that was
released two weeks ago you still can't
find uh useful documentation but you see
how he is and um
in some sense
amateurs so not directly from facebook
or oculus who publish their github
projects where they got the password to
work and shared this way now when you
have an example like this it's actually
very good for a an expert to learn from
those examples but from for a novice
it's actually very hard uh to learn from
examples most examples are too complex
and not easily adaptable to their
to their problem and so i've been
studying this
as well in some of my research but i
didn't make it to big focus
the two things i want to focus on is
really
it's very difficult to design for the
physical aspects of immersive
experiences
and
it's very difficult to plan and simulate
motion in ar unless you are
in ar and you have access to these arvr
devices
and it's also challenging for an
interaction and user experience designer
who has been mostly thinking about 2d
user interfaces and menu driven or kind
of website oriented
experiences where you have relatively
straightforward navigation paths it's
very difficult to design a story driven
immersive experience and so i want to
show you for the next
10 or so minutes i want to take you on a
little tour of
some of the things i've been working on
and
and that is tools and methods to create
these experience more easily for some of
our user groups that i just mentioned
including professional designers but
also mostly novice
arvr
designers so
the tool landscape and this is actually
from a review i did in 2018
that you can divide it into maybe you
see a tool that you have heard of or
familiar with are familiar with um
i would say
the tools that allow you to do the most
arvr so the highest fidelity are
obviously also the hardest
to
use and but we have increasing support
and more traditional interaction design
tools like a vision schedule adobe xd or
figma
and the things you can do on the arvr
side is actually still very limited
there is a whole range of tools that
maybe some of you are familiar with
which are immersive authoring tools so
you are in ar or vr and so you
experience concurrent design
and testing and there are some those
always look very cool when i show you a
video it's similar i actually used one
in my video before i was inside tilt
brush and i was sketching out that 3d
wall
um they're not useful for prototyping
complex
arvr experiences they're good for
storyboarding them and brainstorming um
marquette microsoft marketers may be an
exception because they are becoming a
more ui oriented tool in any case in my
research i've looked at and that's the
dream i guess
and uh the skeptical reviewers probably
think i did not accomplish this but
i see myself somewhere down here i find
that that area very interesting so
obviously you want to achieve a high
level of fidelity maybe even matching
some of these
uh
more programmer oriented tools
but you want to keep the
the skills and resources required uh
relatively low
and obviously this seems like a really
cool thing
i think you could critique my work and
say very clearly michael you're at best
you're like here
but you would agree with me that maybe
the skills and resources are
um definitely we saved some there so
i'll show you some of these
um
this is an exploration of you know young
michael getting started in a rvr in
2016.
um
so i'll show you actually an example
of um
and i i wanted to play a sound now
if it's too loud and um
not so pleasant for you please interrupt
me but i'm gonna
play the sound a little bit
and i need to share the sound
and i wonder whether it's too loud
okay
so
i'll make it a bit softer maybe
so um
a lot of the techniques i'll show you in
the following segment are coming
together here so i've worked on a lot of
paper prototyping techniques which are
familiar to you if you have done
interaction design courses
we use plato and physical materials
quite a bit so
and some of you may guess already what
we're creating here so what we are
creating here together with my students
is a 25 version
of the 250 million dollar version
of lion king
[Music]
you can see some of
the themes in comparison
this one was the hardest scene for us
almost need to use slo-mo
[Music]
and quite cute actually
i still get goosebumps when i watch this
video but i'm looking at the play-doh
version i know you're looking bottom
right and you'll find it so amazing
disney great and michael's
michael stuff
that's so great
[Music]
okay and obviously the sound we didn't
actually we stole it from disney uh
kidding this is a youtube trailer so
it's fine um
so
why did we do this uh
what what were the techniques i just
showed you come together so the lion
king and i will come back to the lion
king example let me actually
change how i share the video we can
optimize for slides again then maybe
this reads better for you
um
in this lion king example lion king is
interesting because it's a movie that
was done in vr and in fact it is a
virtual production and so
rather than record images through the
camera you you track the camera and you
record the traces of the camera and at
the time they were recording the lion
king they had a what we call a
pre-visualization so they had roughly
the characters in there but they didn't
look as nice as they look in the final
render and so it is a very interesting
way to think about the future of
filmmaking and maybe you got excited by
the mandalorian and you've seen things
like that so virtual production is very
interesting and we wanted to study what
actually goes into
creating
prototypes like one of the lion king and
i want to show you a little bit more on
what we can just do with physical
prototyping
so initially in my work i've created a
tool
called protoar
where
what the user can do is sketch out an
experience on paper
then use a few digital techniques to
import it into the computer it uses an
interesting combination of smartphone
and desktop
and it's a tandem interface so you work
with the
smartphone to capture things and preview
things in ar and you do the hard tasks
like placing elements and modeling and
stuff
on the laptop
and so
in 30 seconds i just created a
i mean this was cut together in 20
minutes more likely i would create
an ar furniture placement app like ikea
place
and so i've been working on techniques
that allow you to
very quickly create
ar mobile ar mockups
from paper
at the time we were using marker-based
ar
and you can see that a little bit and
then we developed some techniques where
you
essentially
recapture a couple of times and can
create very interesting interfaces by
coloring and cutting out
so using
techniques to remove some of the
background
and
and then we can also capture plato
models and we don't do
so
manisha garwala who's an expert in
in computer graphics um is somebody who
would be very familiar with 3d
reconstruction of some of these elements
these elements at the time the plato
objects are very small the idea is you
prototype at miniature scale
rather than life size and so 3d capture
of small objects is hard so we developed
a relatively
simple technique where you fly around
the object in 180 degrees or 360 and we
capture the angles on the object and
replay these different angles
kind of like as perspective frames
um when you view the thing in ar and it
gives you the illusion of creating an ar
experience but you can you cannot you
cannot see the objects from angles that
you haven't previously
captured
anyway so this technique is relatively
cool in a clip class because
on commodity
standard smartphones without any ar
capabilities other than a webcam
you can create ar experiences and that
was the point of of this project and
i always like to show some of the
creative art that my students did so you
see ariel one of my favorite sofas and
really also details that are hard to
model
i mean unless you're an expert like
creating a blanket and a 3d modelling
tool tools actually quite hard
but doing it physically
with plato in our studies was actually
fun the students in fact were discussing
the rest of the mobile experience while
they were modeling some of the
characters so we've done a lot of design
jams in my lab
really really for me it's always cool to
show this work and see what we've been
doing anyway so i took it further
into
um this idea of paper prototyping and
testing might be another thing that you
are familiar with if you
if you take some of the interaction
design courses so how does that look
like for arvr so
i will show you some techniques so we
will use a specific template to design
in 360 degrees around an ar or a vr user
but we still have the idea of a person
that is communicating with a user and
facilitating the user study
and we have a person that is
as magretic called a computer in quotes
um
who is
actually responsible for
producing the interface for the user the
facilitator has the additional task of
capturing whatever we put on the
template now with this approach
what can be what kinds of experiences
can we create so i'll show you a little
bit more of the template again this is
uh the principles behind the template
are 360 degree photos
take this sheet of paper and wrap it
around the user and then at the at this
edge and this edge would basically be
coming together behind the user so if i
model an experience
like let's say i want to have a few
butterflies here in front of the user
and i want to put the
user in
scenery with trees and then maybe
mountains you can compose this
experience from three layers or more
and then you can use um
our tool i'm sorry not sure what just
happened i think i pressed the wrong
button but i hope it's still playing for
you
um
and you can create a parallax effect by
just
you know
increasing or decreasing the space
between these layers and now even though
this is flat it's essentially drawn on
paper we can make it a
virtual reality experience i mean i show
you a 360 but you can also see it in vr
on a headset and allow you to experience
that paper prototype so i was very
fascinated i didn't invent the
concepts of 360. but it was fascinating
in using these as a way to prototype
and
so this is what happens behind the
scenes you do need to sketch the layers
according to the template and some of
these distortions are a little tricky
so we didn't invent new tools to deal
with that
and then you map it onto
spheres and layer these spheres and you
can adjust the distance between the
spheres and the opacity
to create these layers
and then you can experience
something like this you could
walk through
one of my
one of my favorite examples is this star
trek
that we created it's the next generation
if you're a star trek fan
maybe you this would look familiar even
though it's a paper prototype
and using then ar you can actually walk
inside your paper prototype which
is cool
and i showed you before how we can layer
um
an experience into foreground background
and background
and we can also
create this room effect by moving one
sphere
uh further away from so not having them
all
intersecting with
overlapping with each other but actually
intersecting them with each other we can
create a room and this is what we
essentially did here so
one layer is the bridge
while the captain's chair the bridge
and in the second layer we created the
observation decks
which is this room and we did a little
bit of cutouts here and inserted the
virtual
virtual background however this virtual
background i remove in ar
so
so the user can actually then see the
real world through it
and so
with this tool called 360 proto we
really we really explored how to make
these
paper prototypes interactive and i'll
show you some of the more experimental
but still fun to look at examples
to see how far we can take it so here we
can prototype an amazon shopping
experience where we place furniture that
is essentially drawn on a on a paper
sheet and displays relative to the user
another thing we one of our crazier
prototypes was recreating this record
experience where
um
my student katie who was a co-author on
this paper she is
using the record and i am the tennis
ball and i'm i was moving the tennis
ball on a there's a lot of things going
on i should want to show this one more
time um oops i went too far
ah damn it let me play this one more
time because i want you to see the
toothpick because i want you to
appreciate the role i had in this
experience as the
and uh
it's a little toy-ish i guess but it to
me it is cool to see with relatively
simple means
okay financially again but now okay so
we implemented first to get an estimate
of the effort this is a vr experience
with physics and so as a wizard um you
can see here on the bottom what i'm
doing i'm moving a toothpick with this
little
tennis ball cut out thing on my
toothpick and i'm moving it relative to
kd on the
template so it requires some
coordination
but actually quite fun
so um
i will re-share
i'm still sharing i will represent
um
[Music]
present again so
um the last thing i wanted to talk about
is some more of the collaborative work
that i've been looking at and um
so
so far you could say but michael your
experiences are very simple the
interactions are quite limited and
and i i know
and i've looked into
prototyping gestures without programming
and using wizard of oz and crowdsourcing
but for the interest in the interest of
time i've decided not to present this
year but gesture wiz is a there's a
paper from 2018 that i've worked on and
it's it's it's actually pretty
interesting
and i was also intimidated about all the
cool stuff that michael bernstein is
doing so he is mr crowdsourcing or used
so anyway um i will focus on
collaborative authoring and coordination
so coming back to our disney example
so we took actually
uh
if you're a phd student and sometimes
deal with reviewer comments
so this work was really hard work we
took to wist where it was destroyed by
one person who said this is crude
programmer art and so
if you feel the same way then i can tell
you i've heard this before but the
principles are what matters we are not
disney we had a 25 budget for the
physical prototype and a 2 000 budget
for the digital prototype and so we
prototyped some of these experiences
digitally but we did it
while
michael now me i'm the director and we
are recreating a scene where rafiki
um
in inhabited by our actor jane
who is in a vr headset
walks up
fried rock not exactly like the way it's
done in the movie but a little bit
similar idea and katie is our camera
operator so i also a cinematographer and
interestingly she uses ar so she uses an
ar device to simulate
and actually move this virtual camera
and so
i'll show you an example of what this
looked like from some of our
test scenes
good acting on jane's behalf
the camera is relatively static
and i said cut and i complained a little
bit and we reshot this scene a few times
um
but i also want you to see what it looks
like for the
the viewer
the experience we actually created so
it's a little dark here because of our
crude programmer art um
we have a
google blogs a google poly model um
rafiki
and the camera movement i wished it were
more pronounced so i gave feedback to
katie you need to move the camera more
and we had to deal with the scale
and so what i studied in this work was
coordinating multiple
designers who are
co-located
using ar or vr and in
and i've
and i've explored different kinds of
spatial coordination challenges that
they would experience and
physical constraints are obviously
the predominant ones and you could you
could could get a bit of a sense of that
just now
by me instructing kd how i wanted to use
the camera her to use the camera
but we had physical space issues and so
we built inside extra director we built
a few tools to rescale and reposition
and recalibrate without restarting the
experience so it's kind of like a
cool paper has some interesting
technical elements to it
but what i was most excited about is
like to me it's one of the
the conceptual contributions of the
paper are really a framework to think
through
spatial coordination and
mixed reality but using
uh
it as a groupware
and collaborative arvr is actually one
of the hottest topics right now at kai
and west and so
i wish more people uh
would
um would build on this work like extra
director which i think is quite can be
quite um interesting so the thing i've
learned and i want to move on to
dealing with
the research
that i'm doing with instructors right
now
is less published work and so more work
and progress but so the things i've
learned so far is the tools i've created
very good for design space exploration
rapid prototyping is definitely
something that works
and accelerates design
and the templates we've used
they guide design but using them is
still difficult so there could be more
research on
more clever authoring techniques and you
do not maybe you can draw
a more 2d and then we can map it onto
a 360 or a 3d sphere and we can
support your creativity that way because
following the the distortion lines is
pretty hard with some of the templates
anyway it's still
often times for end users it's still
difficult to imagine they see it's a
paper prototype even though i was
excited by the star trek um your client
may not
may not see that it's still it's still
difficult to imagine what the final arbx
experience would be like so but i think
we're making good progress on the
fidelity side but it's it's it doesn't
replace an implementation
and um
wizard of oz enables more
goes beyond low fidelity but these
interactive experiences still require a
lot of coordination so this extra
director work is something that i think
is um
is a good starting point to explore
more frameworks and more tools and and
bjorn hartmann's group at berkeley
and bala he's doing amazing stuff over
there a phd student
on uh mixed reality and collaboration so
it's not too far away from you so uh in
the next uh
five minutes if that's okay i wanted to
show you
what i've learned from working with
instructors and now is the part of the
presentation where i feel like i'm
i talk too much and i'm running low on
time and i had planned more content
so i will pick two things um
one is
i will talk you through this one
experience i may not get to the privacy
stuff so anyway
maybe if there are questions we can talk
about it so creating and
one of the things i've done
also for kai 2020 was
creating a toolkit to
support um mixed reality analytics and
we demonstrated this toolkit is useful
to support uh
designing learning activities and so if
you uh in this case we
you don't you don't see exactly what the
students see obviously we are in a lab
environment but they see
an immersive
simulation
and what we did was we worked with a
nursing instructor here going through a
tabletop triage exercise where
my lab
including myself we were
we were given the scenario of arriving
at a disaster and we had to determine
which of the poor people we need to
take care of and which of the poor
people
at this disaster
we can't do much and we should therefore
not prioritize and there's a triage
protocol for that
and it's an interesting experience that
you can do through a tabletop exercise
but what the instructor really wanted is
an immersive a mixed reality experience
so we went ahead and designed a
virtual environment and we scoped it out
using some of
the immersive prototyping tools and
techniques that i've talked about
previously here's
a roth a pre-viz of so you come into
this escape room
and there's a crisis in there there
might be some people who are injured and
it's also bad weather and it's a little
bit of a war zone and
you need to escape this room when it's
safe so you need to pay attention to
when the shootings stop and determine
when it's safe to get medical help
and so we prototype this experience
using
unity and here you see
how it looks on a computer
and then i'll show you in a second what
the actual experience is designed for a
hololens
where the students wear
a hololens and so it's an ar headset and
they get to see you map some of the
content into the lab you see
unfortunately some people who didn't
make it
and as a timed experience to create
stress and it's um
it's also an experience where you
increasingly see
injuries and you get triaged and we can
display these injuries on
um
t-shirts that we created
using marker tracking and here you can
see some examples they shouldn't look
too bad i will show some injuries but i
try to pick portions where the injuries
don't look too realistic they look more
like bacon
as we have two versions two levels of
bloodiness if you're a medical student
it's no problem for you to see glass
coming out of a
sticking out of a body or a bone and if
you're if you're not it is actually not
a really pleasant thing to look at and
so we have um
we can we have created tools to track
what's going on in this immersive
experience
and analyze
for instructors
how the students behaved
how would you even assess how different
students perform in this simulation and
so we created this toolkit
to enable instructors to
essentially conduct some of this work in
their classroom
and
there's more work on how to track things
and analyze things and that i
i would refer you to the paper it's it's
interesting
from uh so i've talked mostly about
design before and design includes
evaluation
and
and i've also been looking at some of
these tools in that space
and um
i
feel like i should make room for
questions sean you should you should
decide with me whether i should show one
more thing for four minutes or rather
open the floor i think you can show one
more thing for four minutes
okay then i will do that and then stop
greedy at 50.
um
so it is recent work that i just
presented at kai so this is interesting
so it's coming back to the original
video and it would be a nice way to wrap
up the work
um i wanted to enable instructors to
teach directly in mixed reality so i
created this tool called excel studio
and
it looks a little bit like
this so
excel studio is inspired by streaming
software and virtual production software
and as the instructor i'm the instructor
in here i have different presets and i
can
while i'm giving a lecture in vr i could
just
show traditional slides or we could have
an activity like here with my students
then i also have mixed reality capture
support for different kinds of
whiteboards here what i'm showing is
kind of like what i would call a light
board
where i'm actually sketching against a
window and you can see me in the
background the real person
and then we also can have very
interesting experiences like here i
could i sketched out
how a perspective camera works but i
sketched it out relative to the
perspective of a student so this is what
they would see in virtual reality so
it's collaborative
it's it's a lecture in vr that you can
perceive through a camera through mixed
reality capture but you can also
participate live in it
in a vr headset
and so extra studio it's called xr
because it supports these different
types of modalities and cameras we can
do ar we can do vr
and i think it's really kind of like a
cool tool that i'm very excited about
using in in more teaching
here at michigan and
i would have more studies and things to
share the immersive views
and the mixed reality capture is
it was definitely i tried i gave the
same lecture three times i stopped
sharing here so that you can you can
feel like michael's really wrapping up
and
on time kind of so um
i am teaching arvo courses and i have
given one lecture three times as part of
our evaluation with access studio more
traditional using slides
more vr centric so from a first person
instructor view and then using
uh the different features of excel
studio as our
um virtual production tool designed for
instructors
and
some of the nicest comments i've heard
was like it felt like being in a real
classroom and with the mixed reality
capture
without the over head of of having
to have access to a vr headset and still
understanding
spatial
concepts like i explained how texturing
works how scale works or how perspective
camera works in arvia
and that was to me was very
promising that the students felt the
benefits of immersion
even without being in a vr headset so
i'll stop there before i over claim and
throw it back to you sean thank you
great yeah
okay
wonderful thunderous applause here if
you can hear it i'm not sure
uh great so now we have time for
questions and so we're gonna do this uh
in a sort of hybrid format so we'll try
to pull some questions from here and
then also on zoom and so if you're on
zoom and you want to ask a question use
the raise hand feature and then we will
uh then call on you and you can either
type your question in the chat or
unm will allow you to unmute yourself
and you can do that but as people are
trying to figure out the logistics of
the online questions are there any
questions in
in person here
and
yes hiya
this is maybe a more meta question can
you hear me well
i think i can hear you well thank you
okay
so when there's a
an area of scholarship or maybe a
platform that is difficult for outsiders
to grasp for example here vr and ar
do you see a framework for a scholar
such as you to try and make it more
accessible so you've shown you've shown
how you've done it in your particular
case if someone else would like to
repeat the same thing in another area
perhaps even non-technical
uh what might a good approach be for
your experience
yeah that's a very cool question
thinking of a few things so some of the
things i've done which is i think
you need to
when i walked around at kai and asked
everybody what mixed reality is which
was the precursor to the actual research
project
i really the the community that was
publishing papers on mixed reality
didn't really agree on the terminology
and that to me so like critically
reflecting on what the community
understanding is uh was and then
actually studying your own community is
actually
so science of science i think is
actually a very very important thing
from time to time um you need to ask
whether we are still talking about the
same things
and so that's one thing the other thing
is in a lot of my work and i wasn't able
to show that too much today
i built experiences that
like an interactive handout
using arvr that i can then give to an
instructor who we've worked with
experienced college teachers with
average
years of experience of 30 years of
teaching math or physics in high school
and this is a
very interesting
type of user to work with so how do i i
don't want to impose new practices and
workflows they have not really used arvr
before how do i get them to imagine
i cannot ask them directly do you need a
vr they will tell you no because they've
been teaching for 30 years and it worked
fine so how do i get them to imagine um
what could be possible and so i i in
in a lot of my work more recently i've
been more focused on
co-design and working and participatory
design but the interesting challenges
you have when you work with people who
have not previously experienced aiv also
priming techniques and elicitation
studies
which is a technical term and
those are i think very good
techniques and tools
to help shape the community's
understanding and also allow new people
to come into the area obviously finally
the tools i've worked on
part of my dream was that the tools
themselves would enable more i use them
in my teaching and enable more students
to do things but
i think the
reflecting on the research approach is
is very interesting so i thank you for
your meta question i thought it was cool
nice any other questions here
uh
yeah in the back
this is sort of a broad question but
what are your what are your thoughts on
the metaverse and how far away do you
think we are to entering sort of
a
reality where we all engage in the
metaverse as well as the real world
yeah so fundamentally
i do not believe
it will exist uh because
it's very interesting so you and i may
be in the same physical location but
then depending on our preferred cloud
service provider you and i may not see
the same thing so if you both run with
amazon we may see the amazon ar cloud or
the tesla ar club and so this matter was
this dream of living together in a
virtual world that is essentially
controlled by different
entities and facebook and oculus might
be one of them
and i find it very different think about
how cloud storage works and how we like
is it on dropbox or google drive
and then but it's worse because you and
i if you want to look at the same stuff
while we're in a physical location it
should be tied to it it's ar and um i
don't know and then
i mean i have seen many black mirror
episodes i i think it is fascinating to
imagine how life could continue in a
virtual reality um i like the movie
upload or that series upload
these are interesting glimpses at the
metaverse and
more fundamentally the metaverse as a
term suffers the same challenges as
mixed reality it's overhyped it's not
understood very well and it's actually
not really well realized
and yeah so
i am skeptical that we will achieve
that
vision it's like
did we ever agree on one computer to do
everything
and so
yeah so it'll be a market
a market share problem
and it will actually lead to a lot more
um
uh
yeah i think diversity
equity and inclusion will actually be
very pronounced um
in this matter whereas referring back to
upload i like it when
and i don't want to put in any spoilers
but
essentially if you only have a 2g
connection to this metaverse your
experience will be very sad and very
black and white and if you are
subscribed to the best cloud service
provider you will get the best air
experience
on the other hand it's not too different
from real life so if you can afford a
good medical doctor you can go and get
the best treatment
we essentially just replicate
um
that so
it's a very philosophical question a
very cool topic to talk about i hope i
shared some of my perspective
with you
great i think we have a question online
from
if you can
either unmute yourself ask to be unmuted
um
okay yeah um hi michael um so um
regarding axar director i'm a little bit
confused is that for um like is that for
creating a vr experience or is that for
creating like a 2d animation
oh
yeah that's right so um
if you think about the lion king um
essentially it was shot as a
as a vr experience but it's delivered
as a 2d movie and so exa director the
work was really focused on studying how
different designers in ai and vr could
collaborate what that would mean for the
director
and
the resulting output can be
a 2d or a 3d model but 2d movie kind of
thing like with the lion king but also
with extra director we could actually
record everything that is being created
and animated
inside
in 3d and so we recorded all the traces
and animations that were created and
actually exit director also exports
scripts and assets
so it is also a prototyping platform for
arvr experiences so
the answer is uh yes in both cases
rather than one of them okay um the only
thing i might imagine could be a
problematic for creating vr experience
experience is your camera might not be
you can't manipulate your camera angles
that much in vr movie as in like a real
movie
right um so so uh in fact for the camera
there was a preference towards using the
ar mode of extra director to move the
camera and for vr i've implemented two
types of cameras one is you use your
head but
as the camera or you get something in
put something on your controller
as the camera which gives you it's a
different perspective when you're when
you're shooting as the director in vr
but it uh gives you more freedom uh with
a hand so
he is very experienced so he's touching
on some of the critical points but uh we
thought of that and i'm happy to share
more with you in our meeting later cool
thanks
sorry i can't uh and start a video for
some reason i can only i mute myself
it's weird
great um i think basically we have time
for one more question if there is one
here or online and i have a question too
if we have time did you want to ask your
question no
your question got answered okay so great
i'll this is the last question then so
i'm wondering this is kind of somewhat
connected to maybe the first question uh
in terms of you know you talked a little
bit about you know there there's this
extended reality experience that you're
going to have through these different
types of headsets but then the medium
that people are experiencing it seemed
like was a little bit different in in
some of these different tools you were
showing so some of them were sort of as
pointed out like a vr movie or xr movie
some of them seemed more like xr games
maybe also you had some like you know xr
vr tools how do you think the medium of
the experience changes the tools and and
can the same tools support these
different mediums or are there kind of
unique differences that we need uh for
these different types of media
yeah so i think a lot of
a lot of trying to find out whether ar
vr is actually a good tool
or media is actually you know sean
the last question is like the hardest it
is
it's interesting it's a chicken and egg
problem i i i um i think um i wanted to
be agnostic in my so some researchers
think of themselves as vr researchers or
ar researchers i have a preference i
approached both topics and i think i do
that in my in my role here as a faculty
innovator with the ex-initiative at the
university of michigan i'll do it the
same way so when
depending on the type of experience you
want to create embodied cognition and vr
so immersion might be the right tool uh
for other for other projects so
meditation projects a lot of my students
work on meditation mental health um so
we often choose vr but i find it
interesting to also explore what ar
could be and so in
i think
these mediums are also shaping along
with the tools most tools traditionally
used to be either a or vr and you will
also see more increasing tools you can
design for both
and um in fact it is often just a matter
of adapting the interactions and
switching out the display and tracking
aspects so yeah i guess my question is
maybe less about the you know ar or vr
or mixed reality and more about the type
of experience right the movie
or the the game or the tool sort of
require these different interactions or
different ways of thinking about it and
i wonder if yeah what you know how much
can a tool that helps you create mixed
reality movies extend to a tool that
helps you create a mixed reality version
of you know um
yeah uh tilt brush for example
all right yeah so that transition is
still
um
[Music]
it's still hard i think it's still an
open research problem like i think i
mean they are speaking i mean roughly
maybe i'm still not sure i catch it
really um on the fact that a lot of
these simulations that i created in this
prototyping experience of the visit of
ours they essentially die more or less
uh
with the
with the present that's how i don't
think that stuff you're asking either so
sean i need to i need to one more time
yeah we'll talk more i like it it's
great um all right and i'm sorry that i
i couldn't get it no no no no no no yeah
we'll talk more um it's great no so
wonderful uh let's thank michael for the
wonderful talk